para el fbi y tienen vínculos con el
supremacismo blanco y el
ultranacionalismo
ellos se describen como ultra patriotas
anti inmigrantes libertarios y
defensores del rol de la mujer como ama
de casa o chicos orgullosos son un grupo
fundado en 2016 por el activista de
derecha a gavin máquinas las autoridades
estadounidenses lo vinculan con un
historial de violencia política pero sus
integrantes aseguran que usan la
violencia solo en defensa propia
suelen vestir prendas deportivas
amarillas y negras y también equipos de
protección militar
generalmente portan armas de fuego y
bates son acérrimos defensores de donald
trump y le han declarado lealtad
abiertamente
sus posturas de extrema derecha que
también incluyen la ponderación del
empresario la abolición de las prisiones
la máxima libertad el derecho a portar
armas y la lucha contra el feminismo han
hecho que sean vetados de plataformas
como facebook insta twitter y youtube
por lo que suelen enviar sus mensajes
por redes menos populares su actual
líder es el empresario enric etario
nació en eeuu pero se escribe en cuba-
el lunes 4 de enero fue arrestado a su
llegada a washington por haber retirado
y quemado una bandera del movimiento
black light smarter que se encontraba en
una iglesia de miami seguiremos luchando
carrió posteriormente liberado enfrenta
un cargo de destrucción de propiedad
además de otros dos cargos por posesión
de cargadores de armas de fuego con
capacidad extra para balas en varias
ocasiones ha negado que el grupo sea
ultraderechista y en 2020 realizó una
breve campaña como candidato a la cámara
de representantes en la que propuso
reformas a la justicia criminal
contrarrestar el terrorismo doméstico
finalizar la guerra contra las drogas y
reformar las leyes de inmigración